[Musik]
new york
wir kommen bei philo cast der neuen
sendung hier auf den podcast plattformen
und youtube das thema heute ist
virtualität und ich für mal mit einem
kleinen beispiel ein ich habe neulich
runescape gespielt das ist so ein
browser online ist es browser na ich
weiß ich glaube ich rollen spiele online
rollenspiel wieder und da konnte ich mir
einen blauen hut kaufen für meinen
charakter und dieser blauen hut hat 1600
us-dollar echte dollar gekostet so was
das geht denn ab der ist halt nicht
physisch also ich kann den nicht greifen
er existiert außerhalb von raum und zeit
in diesem leben in diesem spiel selbst
aber ich habe keine chance ihn zu
begreifen und dennoch kostet er so viel
wie kann das sein
ja das ist ein ganz interessantes
phänomen das ist ein virtueller
gegenstand der im second life immer
häufiger ist dieser blau-rotes ist ein
party gut ich habe von dem auch schon
gehört ich dann auch gerne
der ist gar nicht so selten es gibt ganz
ähnliche gegenstände die noch viel
teurer sind
das geht bis 300.000 dollar für so einen
klub zu seinen virtuellen tanzclub auch
in einem rollenspiel und das zeigt
einfach nur das virtuelle gegenstände
die jetzt nicht wieder völlig richtig
sagst raum zeitlich existieren vivo
existiert an dieser blaue gut dieser
partie hat ja irgendwie nirgends auch
nicht in dem server oder diesem computer
denn erzeugt genauso wenig wie ein
gedanke in unserem kopf existiert auch
wenn unsere gehirn im kopf in erzeugt
also diese gegenstände existieren auf
eine andere art und weise als es
physikalische dinge tun wie ein
wirklicher hut aber nichtsdestotrotz
können sie kausal wirksam sein und eine
eigene realität besitzen ja super also
das ist dass wir ein leuchten dass das
einzige problem ist jetzt wir haben wir
haben paar begriffe hier
die im raum stehen und an virtualität zu
verknüpft sind unter anderem ist es
natürlich die realität und wirklichkeit
aber auch simulationen auf der anderen
seite wie kann ich mir denn jetzt sicher
sein dass etwas irgendwie simuliert ist
und einfach gar keinen also was ist auch
eine simulation die frage und wie können
wir sicher sein dass dieses virtuelle
was ich da seh oder oder spiele oder
irgendwie anders ja genau also in denen
ich mit dem ich virtuell in kontakt
kommen ich kann mir sicher sein dass das
real ist dass es schon genannt aber
vielleicht kann man das auch mal so oft
die frage also ein wichtiger punkt wir
müssen ganz klar die simulation von der
realität unterscheiden und auch von der
virtualität unterscheiden simulationen
bedeutet einfach nur abbildung
modellierung letztendlich auch eine
spielerei wir testen ein system wir
simulieren wie ein vogel fliegt wie ein
flugzeug fliegt aber es liegt eben nicht
wirklich sondern wir sehen von ganz
essentiellen dinge ab wir abstrahieren
davon und die simulation ist im
angewiesen auf die realität
es ist halt ein modell der realität was
nur bestimmte aspekte betont und wodurch
wir bestimmte dinge erkennen wollen wie
zum beispiel der wind um die flügel
streicht und irgendwie sowas aber wir
selektieren ganz stark die simulation
als solche hat keine eigenständige
realität weil sie nur die wirklichkeit
die sie simuliert abbildet oder
repräsentiert auf eine völlig und
effekte und und selbstständige weise als
eine abhängigkeit beziehung anders wird
es bei virtuellen gegenständen wie
diesen blauen party.de nicht so gerne
hätte und du glaub ich auch und deswegen
wird es anders weil dieser blaue party
hut in runescape diese an wirklichen
blauen party hut gar nicht imitiert der
ist bestimmt gar keinen wirklichen party
hut abgebildet nachgebildeten simulieren
sollen da gibt es nichts zu simulieren
sondern der wird einfach erfunden wie
eine neue entsteht und deswegen steht
dieser blaue party thrones cape nicht in
einem abhängigkeitsverhältnis nicht
einem abbildungsverbot zu einem
wirklichen blauen hut sondern erstellt
eine eigene realität da und jetzt ist
die frage
er sitzt nur bislang nur virtuell wie
kommt er aber von der virtualität zu
einer realität oder kann virtualität
reals sein und ich würde sagen sehr wohl
vielleicht jetzt nicht physikalisch raum
zeitlich aber so dass dieser mut
irgendwie interesse weckt oder dass der
hut eine bestimmte rolle übernimmt in
diesem spiel die wir alle nutzer dieses
spiels akzeptieren wir einigen uns
darauf dass dieser rot diese rolle
spielt und wir anerkennen diese rolle
und dann entsteht damit eine gewisse
verbindlichkeit und mit dieser
rahmenbedingungen der verbindlichkeit
entstehen kausale kräfte die aus diesem
mut hervorgehen dieser wert der da
entsteht also ich habe mir ja vorhin
ungefähr eine stunde darüber geredet was
wert ist woher der kommt jetzt auch die
zuhörer können sich jetzt mal vorstellen
das ist ganz argumente runter die ganzen
argumente runter zu gehen und dann sich
vorzustellen woher wert kommt das kann
zum beispiel daher kommt man kann sich
denken ja ok der goldbarren hat wert
weil leute gold als etwas seltenes
ansehen oder geld hat wert in dem sinn
dass es auf goldbarren verweist die man
dann irgendwie zugänglich gemacht
bekommt aber irgendwie scheint mir so
selbst der wert an sich ist hat ist gar
nicht real ist er aber vielleicht ist er
virtuell aber nicht real
und das wäre also meine frage die
geklärt werden könnte ja du hast einen
wichtigen punkt angesprochen von der
virtuellen realität kommen wir sehr
schnell auch zu werten
man muss dazu sagen dass virtualität
oder virtuelle realität nicht existiert
seitdem es computerspiele oder
digitalisierung gibt sondern virtualität
ist schon viel älter wir haben es zum
beispiel mit virtualität dann zu tun
wenn wir von geldscheinen sprechen von
werten die
mit einem scheck bezeichnet sind am der
jackass nur wertloses blatt papier auf
dem irgendwie einge krankl draufsteht
was mir eindeutig zuordenbar ist mehr
ist es nicht
und dieser schecks also die unterschrift
mainz genau oder irgendwie ein
fingerabdruck oder irgendwie ein bloßes
zeichen meistens ist es die unterschrift
und irgendwie bekommt diese dieses
wertlose papiere dadurch einen wert eine
bedeutung mit dieser bedeutung eben auch
eine kausale kraft und eben eine
realität und das scheint mir zu
verweisen auf eine größere struktur die
hinter diesem papier scheint steht die
auch hinter diesem blauen party hut
steht auf in runescape nämlich ein eine
institution eine institution des
vertrauens der absprache der
verbindlichkeit von freien individuen
die sich darauf geeinigt haben und die
auch dafür einstehen dass dieser wert
den man diesen gegenstand zumindest dass
der auch am ende ausgezahlt oder
garantiert wird das ist jetzt eine
wertzuschreibungen auf die sich mehrere
leute einigen was ist aber mit einem
wert der nur für eine person sinnvoll
ist also auch ein wichtiger punkt man
könnte zum beispiel sagen ja dieser
blaue party hut in runescape der gefällt
mir so gut den möchte nur ich und alle
anderen finden ihn wertlos das
sicherlich bekommt dieser partie hat
dadurch einen wert dass nur eine
einzelne person ihm will
das problem ist nur werte sind
eigentlich erst dann werde wenn sie
dauerhaft sind also dann würde selten
darf entsprechend dass etwas an wert hat
wenn der wert am nächsten tag sich schon
ändert also ist dann keiner mehr will
also um damit etwas an wert hat muss man
voraussetzen dass dieser wert eine
gewisse stabilität hat stabilität
bedeutet eine zeitliche ausdehnung über
eine gewisse zeit und auch eingeteilt
das interesse dass nicht nur eine person
da aufgrund einer gewissen laune jetzt
diesen gegenstand will sondern dass es
ein gemeinde interesse gibt das diesen
wert begründet das geht dann auch so in
richtung also mir kommt da spekulationen
sind bei aktien die dann irgendwie immer
beliebter werden natürlich spielen da
die ganzen
kategorien eine rolle die sogenannte
sowie institutionen oder es hat einen
nutzen für jemanden in ca
jetzt ist mir einfach noch nicht klar
was virtuell ist und was virtualität
bedeutet dieser begriff ist gar nicht
klar da hast du völlig recht virtualität
wird häufig als gegenbegriff zu
aktualität der wirklichkeit und auch
realität gebracht häufig geht es in
richtung möglichkeit aber möglichkeit
wäre zu schwach um eine virtuelle welt
der nicht nur möglich ist wenn sie ist
ja schon irgendwie da hat sie steht in
einem gewissen spannungsverhältnis zur
realität die wir uns häufig raum
zeitlich physikalisch vorstellen also
ein virtueller abbilden können wir nicht
rein bei sein virtueller abflachen
geschmack der verdirbt auch irgendwann
nicht der hat keine klare kontur dich
anfassen kann
der existiert schon aber halt mit
gänzlich anderen eigenschaften aber
dennoch kann er existieren und ich würde
sagen dass jetzt mal definitions
versuchte aber nur vorläufig ist das
virtualität eine existenz eine realität
bedeutet die aber unabhängig von raum
und zeit existiert das wäre es ein
erster definitions versucht wir sehen
das ja auch beim geldschein ein
geldschein ist unabhängig von dem wert
den er bezeichnet dennoch versammelt er
diesen wert in sich genauso mit aktien
wo sind die wo liegen die irgendwo einem
server aber da liegen sie gar nicht sie
existieren irgendwo einem anderen ort
der nicht jetzt räumlich und zeitlich
wie bei physikalischen objekten
bestimmbar ist das heißt wir sollten ein
realitäts begriff entwickeln der nicht
nur der logik physikalischer dinge folgt
sondern der eben so was kennt wie eine
virtuelle existenz die jetzt nicht einem
klaren zeitpunkt festzumachen ist aber
dennoch kausale kräfte entfalten kann
auf diese kausalen kräfte kommt zu mir
vor allem an
das ist der unterschied zur simulation
simulationen erzeugen in der regel keine
eigenen kräfte und zwar deswegen weil
sie demjenigen untergeordnet sind dass
sie simulieren
sie können sich nicht emanzipieren und
selbstständig machen virtuelle
realitäten können eigendynamik entfalten
die wir gar nicht absehen können und auf
ganz neue dinge uns hinführen und das
macht die sache spannend aus unter
logischer hinsicht und ein weiterer
punkt auf den du mich vorgebracht hat es
in unserem gespräch
durch diese raum zeitliche
unabhängigkeit eine gewisse freiheit
hoffen unseren körper das ganze internet
hat auch robert dreyfuss darauf
hingewiesen befreit uns von unserem
körper das würde platon und so gratis
diese intellektuelle letzten die antiken
wird das freuen haben die machen uns
unabhängig von unserem körper aber
dennoch sind sie existent die griechen
ging sogar so weit dass virtuelle sag
ich jetzt mal die ideen die reinen nur
bilder als das eigentlich wirklich
anzusehen obwohl es nicht den raum und
zeit existiert sich wie ein konkrete
baum
da muss ich gleich zu sagen wir
nachfragen weil mir kam so der gedanke
wenn wir jetzt einen apfel haben der
virtuell ist und in dem computerspiel
existiert und total großen pferd hat
oder auch nehmen wir die unseren
beliebten blauen hut party hut der ist
physisch nicht existenz haben wir haben
ja uns darauf geeinigt aber wir sprechen
ihm etwas zu er hat irgendwie ein
kontext in dem er auftritt das interesse
da ist da intention et cetera
da dachte ich mir als rückschluss könnte
ich doch sagen dass ein echter apfel
auch nur dann wechsel also ein
physischer apfel auch nur dann existiert
wenn er wenn diese eigenschaften von
intentionen begehe begierde nutzen
vereinbarung halt sind ja erst erstmal
dieser punkt wie ich sie bis zu sehr
kritische stimmen gegenüber
und das können wir auch dabei belassen
dass das nicht klar ist oder dass du
auch der meinung bist du das physische
ist immer als reale bleibt real aber
jetzt in bezug auf die leute die ideen
als etwas noch wirkliches 10 kam mir der
gedanke dass wir jetzt als fazit könnten
wir doch irgendwie sagen
der geist und die gedanken sind die
nicht eigentlich auch virtuell oder
besonders vor allem virtuell ja das ein
guter punkt auf den wollte ich auch noch
eingehen wollen
unsere gedanken scheinen in einer
virtuellen weise zu existieren
ganz ähnlich wie blaue party hüte weil
sie nicht raum und zeitlich existieren
unsere gedanken sind nicht nur zum kopf
sie werden von unserem gedächtnis von
uns zum gehirn erzeugt aber sie sind
nicht dasselbe wie unser gedächtnis
unser gehirn und sie existieren auch
nicht im gehirn wurden wo existierende
gedanke dass morgen samstag ist
existierte ihr vorne
wahrscheinlich aber wo genau vorne oder
vielleicht auch hinten außerdem weiß man
dass im gehirn alles vernetzt ist also
man kann das gar nicht richtig
lokalisieren das wären kategorien fehler
gedanken raum zeitlich zu interpretieren
und genauso dann wie unsere gedanken
nicht raum zeitlich gebunden sind
genauso sind eure virtuelle gegenstände
nicht raum zeitlich gebunden deswegen
wäre ich dafür sehr offen
aber auch unsere gedanken als etwas
virtuelles anzusehen die nicht desto
trotz realität haben können weil sie
bedeutung haben und weil sie sich kausal
auswirken können in dieser welt letzte
frage bezüglich des internets weil das
unser letztes thema war und wie siehst
du denn die informationen die im
internet vorhanden ist es hat ja auch es
ist sie vom selben charakter
du meinst jetzt wir uns gedanken also
vom selben charakter wir unsere gedanken
ja also glaub ja gesagt unser geist hat
oder unser gehirn das physisch und
zeitlich unbegrenzt und aus dem heraus
entstehen gedanken die sind aber
wiederum nicht raum zeitlich zu verorten
und jetzt dahingehend die frage beim
internet ist das doch auch der fall
ja das internet ist also diese ganzen
informationen im internet können wir
auch nicht klar lokalisieren wo ist
jetzt bitteschön eine domain www.net auf
dem server werden
ja aber ich sage mal so die existiert ja
nicht im server direkt also sie ist
sicherlich dadurch erzeugt wie unsere
gedanken durch das gehirn erzeugt werden
aber die blaue farbe des logos
na ja die ist schon vielleicht irgendwie
auf dem server als daten gespeichert
aber ich kann sie eben auch dann auf
mein computer speichern und sie wird
angezeigt bei mir an meinem computer
also ich glaube die lokalisierung von
informationen im internet ist ähnlich zu
verstehen wie unsere gedanken sind auch
virtuell sind nicht raum zeitlich
gebunden sie werden erzeugt bestimmt an
bestimmten orten ganz klar weil sie sich
darauf reduzierbar auf ihren code würde
ich jetzt sagen sie haben gewisse farben
usw
sie werden dargestellt in unserem pc
also gibt es eine gewisse analogie
zumindest ob es genau dieselbe struktur
ist von digitalen gegenständen und
informationen und unseren gedanken und
zu mentalen phänomen da bin ich mir
nicht ganz sicher aber eine gewisse
analogie besteht zumindest schon okay
also was ich jetzt von der ganzen von
unserem gespräch mitnehmen kann ist dass
virtualität besonders also viel realer
und wirklicher ist als ich es bisher
dachte ist er dachte ich virtuell wer
irgendetwas nur rein digitale ist es
existiert nicht und das irgendwie eine
fantasie eine fiktionale welt und eben
genau also wird der virtuelle ist es
viel realer es hat eine kausale kraft
ich kann jetzt endlich mir überlegen ob
ich 1600 euro 1 partyhit investieren
kann denn das ist vielleicht sogar
sinnvoll
und das letzte was wir jetzt auch noch
in den sinn kam war ja das ist eben die
dass die simulation dazu abgegrenzt ist
und keine kausale kraft ist ich kann die
virtualität sozusagen näher am realen
verorten
dennoch scheinen wir das ganze ein
bisschen sagen für mich persönlich jetzt
noch ein bisschen weiter zu erforschen
und ja ich mich interessiert auch was
die zuschauer denken dass deren meinung
zu dem ganzen ist vielleicht haben ja
auch ein paar leute die da ihre ihr
wissen teilen können
aber ja zur nächsten sitzung ist
computerspiele
ästhetik und immersion von
computerspielen danke vielen dank fürs
zuhören und bis dann schaut wie danke
tschüss
[Musik]